Star City is Russia's cosmonaut training
town and it's been around since about
1960 it's hidden in the woods and it
literally was hidden for years I mean it
was it was not on the map
it was top-secret it was like Russia's
area 51 since the fall of communism
they've they've opened up Star City
local tourists can go in and also now
there's this program with the the
private space explorers also sometimes
called space tourists you are paying 30
million dollars or so to go to the
International Space Station first have
to go to Star City for about eight
months to do their training you know
it's a town so people actually live
there it's so people go there to get
trained but there are also 8,000
residents it's more YMCA than Starship
Enterprise so it's it's a bit
that run down if you want to go up as
part of this Russian space program you
have to go to Star City and train so
that's why these private space explorers
aren't going there Richard Garriott is
extremely well known in the computer
game industry and the reason that this
is such a passion for him is because
he's actually the son of an astronaut so
his father is Owen Garriott who went up
to the Skylab in 1973 and later went up
again to the Space Lab and it's been his
life ambition to do this but as a child
he was his his dream was was thwarted at
a very early age when he was told that
his vision was so bad that he would
never be an astronaut so he basically
spent the rest of his life doing
everything he could to get to this point
and had to overcome a lot of obstacles
to get here including his bad vision
which he ended up getting eye surgery to
correct he had to obviously raise the
money which he did through selling
millions and millions and millions of
computer games and he you know he had to
create an opportunity which he did
through space adventures the company in
which he's in a co-owner and now he's
he's finally fulfilling this dream at
the age of 47 and and this is why he has
shipped himself off to Star City to
spend eight months training there for
this trip which will take place on
October 12 in the future whether it is
that we need to leave this planet and
colonize somewhere else whether its
resources that we can get in space or
whether it's simply just you know
tourism and and
another place to go when I explore you
know this is thought to be the first
step and while we can all sit back here
and think wow these people are spending
30 million dollars and what does that
have to do with me
you know the idea is that this is
opening a door that other people are
going to be able to go through in
different ways in the future
you